hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back the nether okay I'm
playing right off the bat of the other
one so I'm gonna chug down this bro max
because I figured that it might actually
be an energy drink or something
well it's good I'm glad I drank that
that was really useful to me didn't even
give me a benefit didn't even give me
like unlimited sprint or something all
right I'm gonna try to find some trouble
this time because I know the last
episode was kind of dry I have guns
I wanna get tested I don't know what
tasseled means but I want to get there I
want to find out other player and I
shove my guns up his butt and then pull
the trigger and fire a lot I'm gonna
steal all of his stuff I want to make
him cry bill baby tears are all these
noobs and scrubs out here I'm too proud
to be bothered by any of them fine too
bro but either way still tried my best
it survived but I am clear I haven't
found anyone else oh let's try to go to
that nether surge those puppy
okay never mind remember okay your dad
did anyone hear that come on bring it on
bring it on bring it huh
ready for you anybody smitty werben
jaegerman jensen come out to play oh
come on give me a challenge face me or
is they'll scared I seriously will shoot
anyone that I see I'm out trying to hunt
for trouble here come on bring it on I
don't even have any med kits I'm an open
walking target oh no I'm just standing
out here in my underwear not looking for
any trouble hope no one shoots me in the
back oh god that would be awful if
someone did that
nothing just lies nothing at all why
would someone make a camp out in the
open when these perfectly good houses
everywhere maybe not perfectly good I
mean the doors are blown off and all the
windows are shattered it's kind of
tilting to its side but hello well hello
there
what are you doing here oh that's so
weird my heart rate just like shot up a
million oh my god like stopped it was
like oh my god exactly another player
well well well what do we have here a
little bit of a showdown you went into
that fast Mart I know you did
now where are you gonna pop out little
boy where are you going to pop out this
is going to be a fight to the death and
I guess I mean your dad you uh I see you
there
oh he doesn't even have a gun I'll try
to be his friend
Hey you can be my new smitty werben
jaegerman jensen come back come back I
want to survive with you or I want to
stalk you and kill you dad I don't know
which not yet anyway hello no you're not
looking at me no looking at me come back
smitty werben jaegerman jensen smitty
werben jaegerman jensen Freddie mini
werben can I call you Smitty three to me
don't you run from me Schmidty got your
rod for mix ready ready where be Eggman
Jetson hi hi I could have killed you a
mile ago but I mean I mean really Minnie
how do I communicate pretty pretty
smitty werben jaegerman jensen pretty
pretty pretty weapon jaegerman jensen
can you hear me Smitty Smitty don't run
from me Smitty shrilly
you hear I don't see it here Smitty
ready ready listen to me ready
ready please please really really please
trying to be your friend just look at me
Smitty
Freddie I already hug you man Jensen
look at me Rita hey man where you been
Jason what are you doing getting your
name's doc giggles now to smitty werben
jaegerman jensen i need to get in front
of him so he actually sees me I've been
following this guy forever he's just
like mmm this guy would die in Ibaka's
cuz he never turns around hi Smitty
hi Smitty hi hi hi only your friend can
you be smitty werben jaegerman jensen
hi wanna be your friend okay cool let's
go go let's go let's go
go ahead come on we're gonna play on the
swings we're gonna swing Swan pretty
pretty worried to go ready I want to be
my friend ready hi what I'm not gonna
shoot you
oh sorry Oh Bob put up take away my gun
so yours is nice right
pretty yeah yeah we're friends
look at us we're friends Oh sweetie
we're in the agreement ensign I missed
you so much
I'm not gonna shoot you in the back who
do that look okay let's go let's go
let's go I got you back oh let's go I'm
totally with it I'm with it I trust you
implicitly a dime with it I'm with it
yeah we're cool
we're cool breath cool I'm gonna help
you survive watching our back watching
our six shoot you so dead can we no I'm
fine what are you talking about what are
you looking at I'm totally I'm gonna
kill you so dead I'm gonna shoot you a
million times in the butt driver I'm
gonna kill you so much I'm gonna kill
you so dead I'm number I already wanna
kill you so much I'm gonna shoot you in
the back in the back in the head I'm
gonna kill ya buddy I'm gonna kill you
you come back here I'm gonna go burn our
shell of your ass they'll be here yeah
yeah come on friend got this got it good
don't worry if any nether come after us
I'm gonna kill them too I mean just them
not you of course it's wicker what you
looking at your map you looking at your
map Smitty you're mad watch TV now hey
buddy hey hey I don't want to kill him
but I have to
I really have to he's the only other
player that I saw no I'm gonna keep
smitty werben jaegerman jensen around
for just will bit longer I wonder if he
could hear me like if I accidentally
press down one of my buttons and I'm
actually talking to Hey
what god this we can take on the whole
world you and I but the whole world ice
means I'm gonna wait until you help me
find something good
kill you know I'm gonna baby is gonna
kill you he's Oh
maybe I won't kill him I'm kidding I'm
kind of going to attach the smitty
werben jaegerman jensen the return to
Smitty werben jaegerman jensen was
foretold long ago long ago I knew would
come around if he finds a gun though I'm
gonna kill him so fast I'm gonna kill
him so fast I think you see anything
Smitty
Renner you see anything guy thing isn't
good no no what good hey y'all you
didn't find anything that's too bad
whoop buddy all right you keep going
Smitty you're doing good you're doing
you're doing great work you're doing
great
pretty what are you doing okay don't
look at that one
Schmidty here making me feel awfully
nervous the way you're stomping around
it looking at me you make me feel
nervous well you know what Robbie we're
always ready hey I guess I could go you
giggle or something like that I can't
believe I made a new friend in this
zombie apocalyptic nest of death and
nightmares Oh what I well what would I
do without you Smitty
don't worry anyone else that I see I
will kill dead but you you're my friend
in this pocket you're my only friend
because I killed all of my other friends
did you not know that they do not know
that's really Freddie
why aren't you talking to me Smitty Trey
where's Mark Moore
my name's not Smitty it giggles - shut
up Freddie
do know what your name is - will you
everything about Jesse did you did you
hear something Smitty something over
there nothing I need to kill come on I'm
over there
oh my need to kill I need two kills
ready I'll kill you dad
would you could get a gun would you get
a gun oh you've had a gun oh you've been
holding out on Marga boy have you Smitty
ah keep it on down don't try to kill me
I'll kill you so dead I'll kill you so
dead trust a me in the back
fan out
what did he actually say nothing like
neither was he just digging with me well
dress him now
really I don't trust you now you really
stop looking at me like that
clearly rely me okay he's good whew me
just you me in the head I don't trust
you Smitty hello Josh yeah was it
hmm oh that's a safe zone oh it's the
Riverside outpost oh I get it I got it I
got it I got it I got it okay so we're
in a safe zone ah good good
then we're gonna be super duper friendly
okay I can't believe I have resisted
killing him for this long I know all of
your just like biting your tongues who's
just like gonna kill him he's gonna kill
him now oh look another survivor hello
shaggy sliff tenant left and it's tea
hello hi there we're exiting safe zone I
thought we were just in the safe zone no
we're in the safe zone so I gotta keep
my eye on you
mm-hm oh good the vendor WoW is that
blown oh that's nothing I'll need a
trade uh nobody wanted one em Tod RTO
career package ooh I do not have ah I do
not have the requested item hello what's
wrong with you weirdo stop looking at me
like that
I have a gun I'm just not showing it to
you yet lost yet anyway these guys are
gonna kill me
Smitty it's you and me against mr. left
tenancy here hi Hey
well rave party rave party go down here
well this is been delightful I'm gonna
go this way
you guys have fun I'm gonna sneak around
and shoot him in the bud just shoot them
so Hardy but they follow me they're not
following me
well well well I think this just goes to
show how untrustworthy they really are
they're just waiting for the time that
they can kill me when in reality I'm
waiting for the time that I they've I
can kill them or they can kill me I
don't know I don't know what just which
anymore they lost scared it load they're
gonna shoot me I know they are okay all
right they're not there believe i'ma
wait for them oh wait this isn't the way
out how do I get out they're gonna shoot
me I know they are they're gonna shoot
me I know they are they're gonna kill me
they're gonna kill me dead gotta wait
them
how do we get out of here
don't trust any of them
I don't trust any of them just any of
them I'm gonna wait in that building up
there i'ma wait oh so patiently
killable when it killed them all ah
goddamn it
ooh one dumb what you me Barney Wow Wow
okay there we go got it dad
I killed it good Gillies dead whoa hello
that's another big one what's with all
the big ones I killed your big ones and
a small one but I don't think that
matters I leveled up pretty good
come on out you heard the sounds I must
be weak right you want to come fight me
yes come on bring it on I'm not as weak
as you think where are you Oh No
speedy anger man Jen Stern we were my
only friend in this Jambi apocalypse
nightmare that isn't actually about
zombies come on your say that again you
all roar that a me one more time hi
blam Mitch five bullets I'm getting
better this
many many women younger man shot did you
come back here I wanted to kill you all
my fans wanted me to kill you god damn
it how many of those are there oh god I
gotta kill so many of them I'm gonna run
out of health before I get to kill
another player which I want to do very
badly although those character is
starting to get very bit developed but I
don't know if you get like bonus or less
experience for killing other players I
really don't know although this has been
a rather eventful day I met a friend I
went into a safe zone I tried to do a
try and didn't do it I killed a lot of
bad guys oh no it was a good day as if
I'm writing this in my journal no I'm
just talking to myself alone in my
apartment talking into a camera that
started recording everything for me I
think I might put this up on the
internet or something maybe awk right
okay that didn't good anything for me
this looks like it's filled with hi-tech
goodies but not really
I miss MIDI Billy Smitty come back you
can blame it all
he was my only friend and he just
abandoned me I'm all alone I'm all alone
I know that you guys were just biting
your teeth just biting your nails not
your teeth you can't really bite your
teeth it's just like waiting for me to
shoot him in the back and I was gonna I
was really gonna but apparently I've
lost my opportunity to do so and I'm all
that time for this part this has
actually been pretty eventful I was
actually having fun
I didn't kill Schmidty but then again
maybe that's for the best
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching I am still a good person even
though I was about to kill Smitty so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always oh my talkie but I'll
see you in the next video
Hey
but
Oh